today we're to talk about a really
important missing factor in subclinical
hypothyroidism and that is zinc
deficiency now what is a subclinical
[Music]
hypothyroidism you're not looking deeper
you can completely miss this condition
now there are several really important
trace minerals involved in thyroid
function iodine in making the thyroid
selenium in converting t4 to t3 copper
involved in the creation of the thyroid
hormone but another one that's not
emphasized is zinc zinc is not only
involved in the conversion from t4 to t3
but it's also involved in the synthesis
of t4 t3 as well as the thyroid
stimulating hormone the hormone that
comes from the pituitary down to the
thyroid itself without enough zinc you
cannot convert these hormones and you
can't make thyroid hormones now this
really is important if you're getting
hair loss alopecia things like that and
if you don't get enough zinc in your
diet you can take all of these take
thyroid hormones but you may not get
your hair back so zinc is very very
important the other problem is once you
have a hypothyroid condition you're
gonna have a hard time absorbing zinc so
the fact that you have a slow thyroid
causes more of a zinc deficiency so to
make this simple if you have any thyroid
symptoms don't forget about zinc one way
to get your zinc is to consume more
shellfish that would be a good thing
seek help or just take it as a
supplement and lastly I believe is ink
is probably one of the most important
trace minerals of all the trace minerals
it does so many different things in
addition to helping your thyroid so if
you're not familiar with that go and
check out this video on this page
talking about this amazing trace mineral
zinc